ja der hans werner olm ist ein von mir
sehr geschätzte kabarettist und er sagt
ja auch das was er denkt es ist leider
so dass wir wieder in einer phase sind
wo wo der der hofnarr nur noch die
wahrheit sagen kann aber
die frage
wie schaffst du das dich da so durch zu
lavieren denn die öffentlich rechtlichen
aber auch die private wollen wir ja
nicht reden die setzen ja auch manchmal
grenzen lässt du dir grenzen setzen
gute frage wirklich es kommt auch die
grenzen an das sind die grenzen die wir
uns alle selber ziehen also meine
grenzen gehen sehr weit das ist schon
richtig dass man bei den öffentlich
rechtlichen aber mittlerweile auch bei
den privaten fast gar nichts mehr machen
kann muss ich dazu sagen das ist sehr
schade aber wir schon kürzlich habe
natürlich die bühne ich kann mich aus
der bühne austoben austoben und das ist
für mich mein freund was ich habe wenn
ich das nicht mehr könnte welche doch
ein kleines bisschen unglücklich weil
wie gesagt das fernsehen immer mehr
beschneidet da waren die eher lockerer
in den sechzigern denke mal ich meine
damals hatten wir einen präsidenten
heinrich lübke wer den zugelassen hat
dann auch in der politik irgendwo das
muss eine sehr tolerante zeit gewesen
sein also von da ist die frage
berechtigt und gebe ich dir auch recht
aber wie gesagt ich habe meine
bühnenprogramme da kann ich mich
austoben und vielleicht haben wir ja mal
wieder eine zeit wo vielleicht
jungredakteure da sind die auch eine
gewisse macht und eine
entscheidungsfindung
haben dass sie sagen können das machen
wir ich glaube auch dass das ist ein
publikum dafür gibt auch vom
fernsehapparat nicht umsonst das
beweisen ja auch deine sendung du hast
ja auch ein großes publikum experiment
er ist ja auch viel rum den letzten satz
krimi rausschneiden
eine gute frage ich glaube die habe ich
auch gut beantwortet